welcome to water's world i'm jesse
waters liberals destroy you and they
can't debate you that's the subject of
tonight's waters words if there's one
thing we learn during the trump term
it's that the left will do whatever it
takes to get their way they'll demolish
anything and anyone who slows down their
radical agenda no matter how much blunt
force is involved no matter how out of
bounds it is the left will commit crimes
to get their way they'll make it a crime
to resist them
all while ignoring real problems and
real crimes that their own policies are
responsible for they've already gotten
away with way too much they've gotten
cocky because the press the prosecutors
and the politicians are all in on it
there's no guard rails the only thing
stopping them now is we the people
this week the left crossed the line it's
getting dangerous
moderate democrat senator kirsten cinema
not going along with biden and bernie's
3.5 trillion dollar tax and welfare bill
was targeted and actually ambushed in a
restroom
right now is a real moment that our
people need in order for us to be able
to talk about what's really happening we
need a build back better plan right now
we we're not going forward we need
solutions to build that better plan need
has
we knocked on doors for you to get you
elected and just how we got you elected
we can get you out of office if you
don't support what you promised us i'm a
survivor of human trafficking and it's
because of the lack of worker
protections
one of the women bird dogging the
senator was a wacky native american
bernie organizer dr sophia marjanovic
yet she's in her 40s with a ph.d
filmed a senator in a bathroom a felony
in arizona where this took place
she's with a soros-funded group an open
border zealot who's always shrieking
about white supremacy
this type of illegal intimidation tactic
should make all democrats ashamed
especially women but the media of course
endorsed it
when you put it in context with what we
have seen there was no threats there was
no offenses there was no no screaming
anderson i've had worse voters might
actually be more engaged and animated on
these issues than we might actually
understand well this is uh one
manifestation of social protests and we
see it going all different directions
but that is exactly what it's coming
from that's a risk that senator cinema
faces
by not going along with these kinds of
ideas i'd like to see how these folks
would react to being filmed and harassed
in a bathroom
even president joe biden downplayed it
senator cinema last night was chased
into a restroom do you think that those
tactics are crossing a line
i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to are
people who have secret service stand
around them
um so it's it's it's part of the process
so an illegal invasion of a woman's
privacy is part of the process joe biden
greenlighted more attacks and that's
what followed cinema was confronted on a
plane back to dc by an illegal immigrant
i just want to know if
you can commit as my senator as you
didn't commit
to passing
a reconciliation
that could provide a pathway to
citizenship
that's the playbook don't think for
yourself just do what we want don't try
to persuade or negotiate just intimidate
i remember when the left used to like
maverick senators from arizona
and this week
the so-called facebook whistleblower
burst onto the scene with a similar
agenda
censorship
francis haugen a democrat donor who was
responsible for blacking out the hunter
biden laptop story at facebook
mysteriously retained an obama lawyer
appeared on 60 minutes and
coincidentally testified on capitol hill
the very next day
she testified that facebook's tearing
the country apart and contributes to
violence oh
and she happens to be speaking to the
january 6th committee
here she is begging for the federal
government to control what information
is allowed on facebook
there needs to be a regulatory home
where someone like me could do a tour of
duty after working at a place like this
and and have a place to work on things
like regulation to bring that
information out to the oversight boards
that that have the right to do oversight
a regulatory agency within the federal
government yes
see what's happening here total setup
just like christine blasey ford just
like the ukraine whistleblower
democrats in the media are conspiring
with her so they can sink their hooks
into big tech and have total control of
the information flow
cnn's don lemon laid it out perfectly
it allows lies to be spread unchecked
so if we say something on this network
that is not true there are repercussions
and ramifications right we face the
consequences if you do that on social
media there are no consequences what we
post on social media or what is posted
on social media should be true
and if it's not true it should be taken
take it down
if it's not true take it down
if it's not true don't allow people to
put it up there have them face
consequences
we're supposed to trust big tech or don
lemon to tell us what the facts are the
guy who pushed the russia hoax there was
no consequences for that
democrats can't control the narrative if
people are allowed to speak freely on
social media so they're trying to end
that
this is the perfect storm created to
give democrats a chance to regulate our
speech and give the legacy media power
over social media and during this
distraction all week youtube and google
announced they won't let anybody that
doesn't believe in climate change make
money on their sites
free thinkers scientists scholars
citizens can't earn a living on youtube
and google by asking questions about
science
isn't that the entire point of science
the scientific method to ask questions
and use reason to deduce the truth
but you can't profit from seeking the
truth there anymore we're in the danger
zone now
but it gets worse
dubai administration just gave the irs a
free pass to snoop on any bank account
with more than 600 bucks in it
they claim they're worried about people
not paying their taxes
and this from a president whose own son
is under federal investigation for tax
fraud and chinese money laundering
the relationship between a man and his
bank is sacred it's like the
relationship between a man and his
lawyer or his doctor
the irs doesn't get to see bank accounts
unless they get warrants or have a
reasonable cause that a crime was
committed
but that's the point
biden is criminalizing everybody
this is an illegal search
people are starting to rise up
and nyc coveted mandates went into
effect and people are getting pretty
fired up left and right
for choosing not to get the shot
but now you can't protest peacefully in
joe biden's america
biden's attorney general merrick garland
is trying to prosecute parents who fight
back against woke school boards
in an appalling crackdown the doj is now
treating those outspoken parents ready
as domestic terrorists and threatening
moms and dads with visits from fbi task
forces
all because left-wing teachers can't
take the heat at these school board
meetings
for teaching critical race theory which
they say they don't
allowing boys in girls locker rooms and
masking six-year-olds
why has public school become so mired in
extremist politics and a permissive
culture that seems to celebrate the
latest popular fads like gender fluidity
and we oppose your efforts
to impose critical race theory my
five-year-old is being peddled
transgender books in her library
teenagers are being served pornography
under the guise of young adult
literature
that right there
is the right to petition your government
that's in the bill of rights
if there's a real threat that's a local
issue not federal jurisdiction they can
handle it but the democrats are
hell-bent on crushing dissent and are
using january 6 to justify the crackdown
maybe garland has a hidden agenda here
pay attention it turns out his
son-in-law's company has made big bucks
from pushing curriculums in schools
one survey from his company panorama
education asked 12 year olds if they're
pansexual whatever that means or gender
fluid or if they're questioning their
gender
his company teaches the principles of
critical race theory to kids see
garland's going to make sure there's no
opposition while his son-in-law can get
rich
while democrats are busy creating fake
problems for power real problems are
happening all across the country and
they're just completely ignoring them
crime skyrocketing in those liberal
cities we tell you about after they
defunded the police
illegal immigrants flooding the border
americans are still stuck in afghanistan
under taliban control and the fbi and
democrats illegally surveilling
republicans the list goes on and on
the left will stop at nothing in their
quest for total control even if it means
destroying america innocent civilians in
our constitution
but we won't let them
it's time for red-blooded americans to
stop playing defense and go on offense
keep making your voices heard and never
ever back down hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else